hey youtubers is Charlie first episode
of legends of tomorrow just the society
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet it is like a hundred percent
better than last season already so the
big stuff first you guys probably know
about Justice Society because they were
at the end of the episode but Legion of
Doom is the other side of the equation
we kind of saw that form at the end of
the episode when the reverse-flash just
rolled up into the submarine like
surprise but this is all
happening in the timeline like in
present day after he fixed flashpoint
for Barry so if you're wondering like
you know where all this fits into the
timeline flashpoint happened then the
reverse flash like when he ran off at
the end of that episode of the flash
showed up wherever damian darhk-- was
and started their plan to change history
because there are no time masters the
reverse flash is an evil time traveler
so he can do whatever he wants now
although you do wonder about time rates
but just going through my top 10 and
some of the biggest Easter eggs so
starting with number 10 meet Nate
Heywood who is citizen Steele from the
comics if you haven't ever read a JSA
comic there was like a really good Geoff
Johns run back in the early 2000s where
he basically becomes living steel kind
of like Colossus only he can't turn the
ability off so he loses all sense of
touch
it gets really sad but basically they're
using the character in a slightly
different way I believe this is
commander Steele his grandfather so
presumably the professor who's kind of
like Indiana Jones this season we'll
learn about his abilities and will
become the next commander steel in the
future so like when we have the big four
night crossover maybe his powers will
manifest maybe that'll happen at the end
of the season but either way he is a
member of JSA in the comics he has
powers we'll probably see that happen
sometime this season so number nine
though arrow crossover Oliver Queen I
know you're the green arrow I need your
help I think your friends are in trouble
Oliver gets to have a little fun on the
Timeship they wake up Quint I think you
make is like the Quint
the grizzled veteran who's just sitting
around sipping a beer and every scene so
I like the way they jump back and forth
in time between you know telling the
story in present-day like narrating what
happened as they cut to flashbacks of it
actually happening in the past so number
eight the team has been serving as like
the
time masters trying to chase down time
criminals from messing with the timeline
but they find out about the atomic
explosion in New York even though our
man from the Justice Society showed up
and told them not to go back there like
if you go back there it's gonna end
terribly but they go back anyway so at
the end of season 1 if you didn't see
legends of tomorrow season 1 our man
crashes another version of the Waverider
as they're getting ready to take off and
says wait wait wait what you're getting
ready to do you can't do it it will end
in disaster and then he says I'm Rex
Tyler from the Justice Society of
America and it just slams the black but
now we learned that what he told them
after that moment is that they could not
go back to 1942 so of course if they're
not supposed to go back that means they
will totally go back and it'll
completely go sideways we learn number 6
Sarah has been plotting her revenge on
damian darhk-- and he is behind the atom
bomb so they have to go steal Einstein
number 5 Einstein is a pervert that was
so much fun I did like the Einstein
actor in the dialogue they gave him like
he's kind of a dirtbag
but he also catches up really fast like
oh you guys were time travelers I get it
and then he gives his wife credit later
which is actually historically accurate
maybe not for Einstein but at least for
a lot of scientists making discoveries
in the past like there's a long history
in the scientific community of male
scientists taking credit away from
female scientists for big discoveries so
that's kind of what they were doing here
but I don't know if there's any evidence
of Einstein actually doing that in real
life history but they were just kind of
winking at that idea of you know female
scientists not getting credit for big
discoveries that they were a huge part
of but actually jumping back to that
previous point you know about Sarah
trying to save Black Canary
by killing damian darhk-- in the past
obviously it didn't happen in this
episode but that's not going away like
she's gonna keep trying to save Laurel
so I'm wondering when Katie Cassidy
shows up if it's flashback Laurel before
she became Black Canary it just depends
on where they show up in the timeline
when we see her but Katie Cassidy is
going to guest star on legends of
tomorrow they just they haven't
specified exactly what she's gonna look
like but number 4 they put the team back
together after they had been scattered
by a rip hunter he takes off for parts
unknown but he is still a part of the
season so you just have like the funny
montage
everybody's stuck at different points in
time Rey is stuck in Jurassic Park 70
million years ago firestorm is stuck in
the Renaissance Sarah is being tried as
a witch during the Salem witch trials or
lezzing out with the entire town comedy
lesbian nice and then number three you
meet the Justice Society don't you go
anywhere were the Justice Society of
America and we're gonna kick the
out of you
so obviously the next episode they'll
take them back to the brownstone that we
saw from the trailer that's the JSA
brownstone that you read about in the
comics so we'll see the table we'll
learn about their history I'm guessing
that they're all from the 1940 like this
current time period like this is
present-day for them as they're back
there with Einstein so you have like
commander steel that it kind of explains
how commander steel can be citizen
Steel's grandfather so we'll meet all
them it looks like it's obsidian
commander steel vixens grandmother who
is also called vixen just like a
slightly different version of the
character star girl in our man but we
might meet other members of the Justice
Society and a lot of people like
obsidian is Alan Scott's son does that
mean we're gonna see Green Lantern maybe
during like the four night crossover
totally could potentially happen I'm not
expecting it but I feel like they'll
address it at some point and you have
Jay Garrick who's busy doing flash stuff
with Barry this season we'll probably
have some sort of Justice Society
crossover during the season maybe during
the four night crossover you just you
can't do the Justice Society without
doing Jay Garrick because he was a
founding member of Justice Society but
the way they're playing with it and
taught like you know it takes place
there in the 1940s Jay Garrick is more
of a modern character on these shows
right now so we'll see how they deal
with that but if they have a reverse
flash on the Legion of Doom then they'll
need a flash to defeat them so number
two reverse flash shows up at the end
surprise and they move on to
Phase two whatever phase two for the
Legion of Doom is going to be so the
Legion of Doom this season is going to
be the reverse-flash damian darhk-- who
you've already met Malcolm Merlyn is
going to be on the team and Captain Cold
there might be others but those are just
like the big names Captain Cold because
of all the time changes that Barry has
made is now super evil so he's going to
be a big villain on legends of tomorrow
but number one of course big four night
crossover obviously it's going to be the
last night so it'll be the conclusion of
for a night crossover like whatever
happens over those first three episodes
you know Supergirl flash arrow they will
resolve the conflict on legends the big
villain of that is going to be the
dominators from the invasion storyline
Todd McFarlane's invasion story like the
guy that created spawn so if you haven't
read it it's fun to check out but
there'll be a lot of Easter eggs for
that invasion storyline popping up on
the different shows like we've already
met one on Supergirl
in MA Nell who's ad Aksumite the DAX
mites were part of the big invasion
storyline so it really helps if you
watch all four DC shows so if you're not
sure which channel they're on because
they're not all on the same channel
internationally just be sure to find a
way to watch all of them so that you can
keep up with the storyline so it'll be a
lot more fun when we actually do get to
that for a night crossover and you'll be
able to understand what's going on but
obviously I'm going to be doing videos
for all this stuff so let me know in the
comments though like what was your
favorite moment from the episode seeing
the reverse flash seeing the Justice
Society it's really only like the first
half of a two-part premiere so like next
week's episode will be the rest of that
we'll learn all about the Justice
Society and how they're going to fit
into this DC TV universe its way but
I've already feel like the show is a
hundred percent better than last year
just like arrow is a lot better than it
was last year legends of tomorrow was
like torn apart and rebuilt from the
ground up that's why rip hunter isn't
the leader of the team anymore that's
why the Hawks are gone they just
completely changed everything and it's
already 100% better
so we'll say congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Wooper MC you win
a $20 Amazon gift card I'll do a DC
giveaway every week it just runs through
all my DC videos so just start a new
round now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video I will be doing a Jesse quick
flash trailer video in the next day or
two so I'll just remind everyone when I
post that so a whole bunch of DC whole
bunch of Marvel stuff happening right
now I need to catch up on Luke Cage and
I will post an Aquaman mera video next
just because that's a pretty big deal
like we finally learned what mirror
looks like so Getae is gonna be awesome
I'm really excited about legends Justice
Society this season while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
that rogue one trailer again and you can
click here for my flash video from this
week thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys